Caption: la sesión before lunch we need to learn
Caption: about from Dylan in de sorry
Caption: ah that's right all right so right so go
Caption: my I mean I was a junior developer bank
Caption: best or two maybe three years and I
Caption: spent a lot of lifetime networking
Caption: I then very quickly realized that
Caption: breaking things was a lot more fun than
Caption: building them so this is more active
Caption: what I do now having penetration Festa
Caption: of a receive you
Caption: but that's always they don't get told
Caption: you about today I'm gonna talk about
Caption: fashion beside myself and a friend of
Caption: mine we maintained quite a lot yeah
Caption: great outside the patient will evoke med
Caption: school we've been doing this for five
Caption: years now and we were very early
Caption: adopters for both react every noise as
Caption: part of that I've written a lot of
Caption: JavaScript so that's just a bit
Caption: background around me one thing I really
Caption: enjoy doing is trying out different
Caption: programming language just like any five
Caption: I see it up open a new language or a new
Caption: framework I'm immediately right in there
Caption: checking it out seeing what pages the
Caption: language has to offer and you know what
Caption: gauges language past years of law school
Caption: and you know about a week maybe couple
Caption: of months but eventually all have to
Caption: move on front and I kind of go back to
Caption: my day to day which is most niche novice
Caption: prepositional call that even he doesn't
Caption: do anything in production with these I
Caption: still think there's a lot of value in
Caption: trying them out right because they all
Caption: but emphasis is on different aspects of
Caption: software and even if you just try them
Caption: you be more aware of those things when
Caption: you go back to alexei secretary lovely
Caption: rust there's a language which has a big
Caption: focus on this idea of memory safety kind
Caption: of memory ownership so if you've got a
Caption: lot of rust under that the job obviously
Caption: Java memory is all handled for you by
Caption: the runtime however often purva trust
Caption: you be more aware about how you would
Caption: using memories with any program and kind
Caption: of hypoxia gramma and well those off the
Caption: garbage collection hence to where it's
Caption: at
Caption: and currency issues and things like that
Caption: pastels of the big one thing I used to
Caption: run a lot of Pascal the ire of many of
Caption: my friends and colleagues and a scalpel
Caption: is a huge focus on this idea of
Caption: encapsulating side effects and kind of
Caption: minimizing to state so it wants to be a
Caption: very same language so after writing has
Caption: gone for several months I eventually
Caption: went back to stay shop at this station
Caption: off I was not writing was much more
Caption: functional you know I was trying to run
Caption: my code in the way which we minimize the
Caption: side effects of path and another nice
Caption: result of this was the trade-off nail
Caption: writing was so much easier to test
Caption: because of this and I may have reached
Caption: the same conclusion if I was banging my
Caption: head against about men you know six
Caption: months but I feel like trying something
Caption: that was story different really
Caption: accelerated that loading process is
Caption: really a little bit better so languages
Caption: which quote my life was a little foreign
Caption: language called L so L was a functional
Caption: language and framework for doing single
Caption: page kind of this in the same spaces
Caption: angular react five years ago and this
Caption: was very much under peak of annual one
Caption: like annual one was people going to be
Caption: kind of framework for Billy's web
Caption: applications reactant is just like this
Caption: very early releases I was the mitigating
Caption: fraction but it was still very much it
Caption: was a paramount angular world so a big
Caption: company was really nice product a little
Caption: I really enjoyable I guarantee no
Caption: runtime exceptions a nice refreshing
Caption: change from JavaScript runtime
Caption: exceptions yeah that I was trying to
Caption: language out and it looked quickly asked
Caption: next to it was even earlier element it
Caption: was for react to the times the certain
Caption: aspects of the language which was a bit
Caption: difficult so you know I tried it couple
Caption: things but I've actually had to put it
Caption: down and I've moved on and became a
Caption: react developer redox came out it go
Caption: through state management library for
Caption: react Docs is heavily inspired by Holmes
Caption: burger that like this kind of went on
Caption: and then check back in with Ellen kind
Caption: of you know those major release for
Caption: someone didn't go on it either check it
Caption: out and see what had changed in the
Caption: language and with its release it got
Caption: more and more polished and it eventually
Caption: got the finalist two years ago replica
Caption: you know what the nothing's changed in
Caption: his time for me to pick it up and kind
Caption: of see what's changing I'm actually use
Caption: this out and it was like it was nice and
Caption: I tried I think I had out all the issues
Caption: I have the language he just became a
Caption: really pleasant experience and it was a
Caption: really refreshing change because by this
Caption: point I've been running reactant
Caption: production for like three years and I've
Caption: written so much JavaScript minutes ago
Caption: so it's time to get really frustrating I
Caption: feel do different
Caption: I feel like it's a really important
Caption: language whereas own puts a lot of focus
Caption: on name develops friendly and I think
Caption: this is really interesting right so we
Caption: have been multiple folks in today rate
Caption: but we will dis focus on user experience
Caption: we build the best user experience for
Caption: our customers we want to write software
Caption: is easy to use and friendly and
Caption: intuitive to find all these things right
Caption: how it really feels like the tools and
Caption: languages we use are stealth
Caption: this is kind of push to the back of our
Caption: minds like it's not not really a concern
Caption: I think that's really sad like we have
Caption: to use this stuff and yeah it should be
Caption: as much he is I want to talk to you
Caption: about today I wanna share with you some
Caption: of my frustrations with the cardboards
Caption: web development I'm gonna talk about and
Caption: then we'll finish up with a bit of live
Caption: project because I think any tool or I
Caption: chose to try to sell you a programming
Caption: language might actually use it and it is
Caption: gonna be a bit of a letdown
Caption: so I with all that said let's poke about
Caption: JavaScript said Java scripts are really
Caption: strange language right like I know I
Caption: think people better say that it was
Caption: designed in 10 days
Caption: I don't know whether or not that's true
Caption: but I think we can hold it great that
Caption: wasn't intended for building large
Caption: scalloped edges used - like a little
Caption: descriptive browser which is really
Caption: weird because you know idle this went
Caption: down using it to build thousand lines
Caption: single page applications we're running
Caption: it on the back end enjoyed a srt8 in
Caption: service environments like AWS they
Caption: wasn't paying attention
Caption: the art himself recently announced that
Caption: you can write Excel macros and
Caption: JavaScript as well which is fantastic
Caption: for me as an investor because making
Caption: malicious documents with experience
Caption: between of the odds I really appreciate
Caption: that pretty close so yeah despite you
Caption: know this kind of meet your eyes the
Caption: language itself is actually really weird
Caption: like people these with various like it's
Caption: up to equality operators or either the
Caption: whole promise callback event loop type
Caption: thing that I've got a lot of people
Caption: virtually understand and this is all
Caption: you've come to these things quite early
Caption: on which is with because JavaScript I
Caption: think it's safe to say it's the lowest
Caption: price entry of any programming language
Caption: like every web browser including a
Caption: JavaScript console in the JavaScript
Caption: rebel I can tell my grandma right that
Caption: right now today to press f12 and she
Caption: could be upgrading javascript in like
Caption: five minutes
Caption: present my house to could go and run a
Caption: Java program to be like download the JDK
Caption: from articles most likely but it's still
Caption: in a happy boba and then you want to
Caption: exit out of that
Caption: it's all about surprise it's really
Caption: complicated
Caption: where's the JavaScript it's like button
Caption: and everyone can do this so it's really
Caption: strange about this - no very dangerous
Caption: go to the course other quarks are being
Caption: dynamically typed and kind of like
Caption: implicitly converting things to
Caption: different folks a couple of additions
Caption: that obviously gives you a runtime error
Caption: is especially valuable then you get into
Caption: the whole backs process event look by
Caption: still develop this works this is fairly
Caption: trivial to solve it otherwise it wasn't
Caption: running it's very strange and then we
Caption: get into the build tools I've never been
Caption: more frustrated than configuring jobs
Caption: for the build tools every six months is
Caption: a new one and they're all terrible
Caption: and then finally JavaScript has well it
Caption: does not stand it up refill offended by
Caption: because not the full function so that's
Caption: that vm that paddle from a year ago with
Caption: someone who's the package from India
Caption: so is undefined
Caption: hell no man asleep a very good solution
Caption: at main job the language it is
Caption: today so Java sir had one of them
Caption: include notes next example we've got to
Caption: empty arrays and I try to add them
Caption: together they obviously this would make
Caption: any sense does make sense to add rice
Caption: there should be a pair of the Java
Caption: scripts gonna let us do it anything
Caption: I suppose and movingly we could say that
Caption: addition of arrays is under black
Caption: concatenation in which case if you can
Caption: can't get to it if you're right
Caption: obviously you've got another name if
Caption: you're right I'm gonna take this to go
Caption: check go check let's try to get the
Caption: empty string is definitely a five so by
Caption: adding the empty object to the NVRA and
Caption: guess what we get in this case zero even
Caption: the string object object that's not like
Caption: a queue special value that's literally a
Caption: stranger those letters that makes
Caption: perfect sense initiative as you can swap
Caption: the arguments now we have the object you
Caption: get the number zero so we don't think of
Caption: returning strings anymore I don't
Caption: completely different was fantastic I got
Caption: the two more examples this one is real
Caption: awesome professional JavaScript
Caption: developer this
Caption: it's the water cha this is so much more
Caption: so got yes sex with a baby we've got
Caption: polyfills we've got immediately invoked
Caption: function expressions we've got fetch
Caption: we've got asynchronous one that is
Caption: consistent as common has browserify
Caption: I still don't fully understand browser
Caption: public engagement once it was something
Caption: about impact isn't the problem
Caption: I don't know why you needed it but it
Caption: was there right your uncle web pack each
Caption: of these build tools is better than the
Caption: previous one by some arbitrary metric
Caption: we've got cool backs and promises then
Caption: we get up in games brightest package
Caption: manager ability said wasn't so we were
Caption: young it's a better package manager this
Caption: is what javascript is like right so
Caption: where this leave us
Caption: that leaves me really frustrated like I
Caption: have to write and maintain more tests
Caption: and spending time debugging runtime
Caption: errors will often result just from this
Caption: simple timeline obviously up of more
Caption: dependencies we've all seen a node
Caption: modules all right you know the hundreds
Caption: of thousands of dependent packages for
Caption: really simple application and enough
Caption: [Music]
Caption: language instead of like oh crap oh and
Caption: how I think it does things silencer so
Caption: as I said before almost a language which
Caption: compiles down to Java scripting language
Caption: and lives in the same spaces it has a
Caption: fairly decent standard library and built
Caption: into it like strangers have left and
Caption: right type functions so we're already
Caption: one step above JavaScript that it's also
Caption: got full charge of inter operation and
Caption: this is really nice if you're trying to
Caption: integrate now into an existing
Caption: application you can essentially convert
Caption: both data between your existing
Caption: application and
Caption: but there are a few areas where I think
Caption: only really shines and the first of
Caption: those domain is type system so it's
Caption: strongly and statically type and this is
Caption: it and provided a number of guarantees
Caption: basically eliminates the whole Austin
Caption: Powers right and it's through this pot
Caption: system that let me say about the node
Caption: runtime exception and this is a hundred
Caption: percent true of my experience I we're
Caption: gonna break a lot of it at this point
Caption: and I still have one spot of exception
Caption: I'm going to think obviously with static
Caption: types and their own conceptions we've
Caption: got more compiler errors but all tags
Caption: are really interesting approach to this
Caption: because usually to a bar letter is it
Caption: still feels let people to write compile
Caption: this is the 80s or even earlier but you
Caption: just get some kind of cryptic error code
Caption: or a boyfriend so this can be really
Caption: frustrating particularly in languages
Caption: like Java a scholar tools to have very
Caption: strict splat systems
Caption: well than it could feel like you all
Caption: fighting the compiler preventing you
Caption: from doing what that equals very
Caption: classrooms approach that this is a penny
Caption: the fire effects that focused on just
Caption: making the co-pilot Armas is as simple
Caption: and easy to read as possible and they
Caption: really truly uh probably know just the
Caption: best errors I've seen the best pairs of
Caption: any software I've ever used
Caption: like it's really amazing how helpful
Caption: the next thing that happens is again
Caption: something I haven't seen in another
Caption: language it can enforce semantic
Caption: versioning of packages so if you try to
Caption: push the package and know all your
Caption: change has a breaking API change for
Caption: example if you change the type signature
Caption: of one of the functions in your package
Caption: obviously you're going to break people
Caption: that use them that back your friends
Caption: they get a pull your change and their
Caption: codes don't know we're going to compile
Caption: because the types are different
Caption: so what Mel does in this case is it
Caption: forces you to make that the major
Caption: version bubble because the package men
Caption: from the compiler work together to
Caption: ensure that guarantee of everything is
Caption: correct and this is again something I've
Caption: seen in on languages and it's really
Caption: reassuring if you're performing in
Caption: operated one of your dependencies you
Caption: see it's a minor version change you know
Caption: you can just pull it straight into your
Caption: application and you're gonna be writing
Caption: anything much I'm evil still and lastly
Caption: the velocity really trying to spell made
Caption: this pact that it includes the building
Caption: application is called a known
Caption: architecture so this is just kind of
Caption: booming these are interfaces one of the
Caption: big inspirations for redux for those of
Caption: you familiar with that and it's just so
Caption: that's not that I want to go into get
Caption: more detail that's when the pipe system
Caption: stuff how many photos
Caption: I love repo protectionist a problem idea
Caption: out west
Caption: Richmond and then we'll do it so I think
Caption: we can all agree that skydiving is good
Caption: but especially for building large
Caption: applications I mean that's why I skirt
Caption: is as popular that is and as I said
Caption: before elmo is from latest static in a
Caption: way that is alien to us both I've been
Caption: Princeton essentially get away with
Caption: watching your code and never have to
Caption: specify copilot we just kind of figure
Caption: out what high school good using and I
Caption: just barreled up for you so you can
Caption: actually write like you're running jobs
Caption: you never have to run but you still get
Caption: that safety than the time system
Caption: provides home also goes one step further
Caption: than other statically typed languages
Caption: shopping job
Caption: so element doesn't include any multi
Caption: role where it's at least because most of
Caption: my issues with say Chopin Java is null
Caption: pointer exception they kind of just a
Caption: cold that shouldn't exist right
Caption: and so eliminates this might enjoy
Caption: putting those and obviously I think the
Caption: C chopper chopper but I'm following
Caption: surgeons as well but piles propulsion
Caption: Hospital surviving but he was I think
Caption: everyone's meant realize this is the
Caption: light bulb
Caption: yeah and it's through this this also
Caption: makes refactoring like really nice right
Caption: because come to the fact that the
Caption: compiler error message is so helpful if
Caption: you wanted to a great factor I don't
Caption: know we need do is make go read back
Caption: that what the compiler messages and then
Caption: let's take up a little bit figure out
Caption: right this is really so an example of
Caption: this was before I decided to pick up an
Caption: old project I kind of dropped about nine
Caption: months and I realized when I fixed it up
Caption: there and let that each a hop
Caption: implemented and say you know I closed
Caption: the repo I had a look around trying to
Caption: figure out what I was doing where I was
Caption: in a program and implemented the
Caption: functionality so it actually took me ten
Caption: minutes to remember what I was doing a
Caption: great familiarize myself with it and
Caption: then I spent maybe another ten fifteen
Caption: minutes actually coding off the rest of
Caption: the paycheck and I've got a lot more
Caption: errands tonight normally would I make a
Caption: change and then the compiler tiger hey
Caption: names what thickness over here or any
Caption: content is here as well and so
Caption: end-to-end thanks to the compiler in
Caption: this pipe standing I was a believer from
Caption: not seeing that both
Caption: but nine months to completing the finish
Caption: my bread is never soft and you'll be a
Caption: lot
Caption: well obvious if I just walked you
Caption: through a couple of them for a couple of
Caption: assists this is the best one so what
Caption: we've got here is we've used an
Caption: expression which is kind of like return
Caption: rate but we return different values from
Caption: each of the branches so the reason this
Caption: is an error is because we're assigning
Caption: it to a variable we don't know what the
Caption: resulting talk with that variable is it
Caption: might be straight or I'm getting normal
Caption: so basically best case we bucket is the
Caption: actual file and it's causing the issues
Caption: then we have the actual error itself
Caption: smooth on the branches of this it
Caption: produced different types of values again
Caption: I feel this is pretty standard but I
Caption: think it does a little bit better that
Caption: this is an actual English
Caption: very easy graded on this end
Caption: the only another language is he muskeg
Caption: Paulo was right not a type mismatch
Caption: arrow something my eldest being a little
Caption: polite Aaron actually English then
Caption: moving on we've got again the Len number
Caption: which is but actually because one step
Caption: ahead includes the actual offending line
Caption: that is causing the error and the lows
Caption: the whole one in this money that's just
Caption: part of the line it will on the line and
Caption: friends what the actual part of it is
Caption: that's holding an issue and this is
Caption: fantastic right because this makes I can
Caption: just look at this era and then jump
Caption: straight back to the code nice to know
Caption: what I need to change and where what the
Caption: issue is rather than just gave a line of
Caption: it maybe like a ball stand in the line
Caption: of monthly how many times I've got that
Caption: offset and end up either left my cursor
Caption: through that I figure out where in the
Caption: line I'm actually made a mistake right
Caption: well the whole thing's right know
Caption: exactly what the next section is we get
Caption: actual types which I miss matching then
Caption: again you kind of get this one step
Caption: further it tells you which branches with
Caption: you might and although in this example
Caption: is perhaps most important see very
Caption: clearly stated how the world is the
Caption: string is what like 90 values and we
Caption: were calling other functions in these
Caption: branches and then will be immediately
Caption: obvious which which which branches
Caption: mismatching or which types or at any
Caption: point any kind of the icing on the cake
Caption: is always began one step per that
Caption: provides this extra hint which is these
Caption: need to match so we
Caption: this is really nice right comes the
Caption: composite or anything close to what
Caption: we've done wrong bed Tiger officials
Caption: impose why that's a problem
Caption: that's okay really feel that that level
Caption: of context is not provided in next
Caption: example we've made it by foot over there
Caption: and I'm trying to access the field on
Caption: that variable first name again moving to
Caption: write Alice's because then the stuntman
Caption: again well in plain English really easy
Caption: to understand and I variable again we
Caption: get the line on that any extra any
Caption: parties and other lines we don't exact
Caption: equations but the actual driver as well
Caption: so we don't have a palace it's a person
Caption: does not come and go
Caption: does this whole belly stretch boy go
Caption: back home because one step further again
Caption: is it from Isis extra hint which is the
Caption: record fields to not jump maybe you make
Caption: these five of us so the person doesn't
Caption: lose it'll call first there a typical
Caption: dose this he's trying to access to the
Caption: server man and this person and you can
Caption: see that these people
Caption: flex it but so it's like maybe you've
Caption: never seen this final example we've got
Caption: the right people they know about first
Caption: name but the lost operator and Ellen is
Caption: terrific for numbers
Caption: you don't use it the string
Caption: concatenation because we've all seen how
Caption: bad they like message JavaScript so
Caption: again we get the line number and
Caption: underline that doesn't match plus is
Caption: expecting the left argument to be the
Caption: argument is a string again what's this
Caption: extra Hindi goken strings that no
Caption: mediate you so this is amazing not only
Caption: does it detected positive type error mr.
Caption: any exists train with a bus operator but
Caption: at those that it's a string he's using
Caption: an applause all right you must be trying
Caption: to append strings but I will provide
Caption: this extra in but you know it's actually
Caption: append strings you need to use this
Caption: other operator here's the document
Caption: and again I've never seen this in any
Caption: other language it's really nice just a
Caption: really pleasant developer experience
Caption: yeah so that's kind of an example of
Caption: some of the papyrus is happening to
Caption: raise data that it's so much better than
Caption: the other error messages in place this
Caption: is definitely one of the wise Grunfeld
Caption: own pushes for a better user experience
Caption: arrangements really is the old
Caption: architecture so it's a pattern book but
Caption: we have the pensions in Nome it's Bailey
Caption: haven't integrated with the language but
Caption: it's you know all the articles and
Caption: tutorials use it's easy to use as I said
Caption: before it's a relapse for those of you
Caption: who use that library and it's it's very
Caption: easy to use is this idea of going in one
Caption: direction and this makes it really easy
Caption: so this is the entire space of your
Caption: application this includes all things
Caption: like any thought of loaded pro it guys
Caption: us stay in this problem and having this
Caption: whole lot that's really great because it
Caption: means not only it's also very easy to do
Caption: to test the people so what you can do is
Caption: you can export this as a JSON object or
Caption: a test value and basically is important
Caption: so if you put a test them and the tester
Caption: funds the feedback been in your software
Caption: that has been exported that model and
Caption: use the developer can just import it
Caption: back into your program and you can be
Caption: that the exact same the next component
Caption: is the view so this is fairly
Caption: straightforward the view is basically a
Caption: function which takes a model and just
Caption: returns HTML or draws it to the screen
Caption: there's really a lot of magic going on
Caption: there it uses a virtual Dom doing all
Caption: this rendering much the same way that
Caption: reactors you know lonely update and this
Caption: is where the of your budget
Caption: you handle a couple's so thanks messages
Caption: from the view messages can basically be
Caption: anything from the Thomas inch base coats
Caption: like the user clicks on a button or they
Caption: try some meaningful field these will
Caption: generate messages but also the non
Caption: interactive events like an API call
Caption: completes that message the second thing
Caption: in thanks is the particle so with these
Caption: two pieces of information update
Caption: function unless it's out you know so I
Caption: say they use Eclipse a toggle that
Caption: message we're going to the update
Caption: function will go into the update
Caption: function will change the model and tweak
Caption: the state of that and then you know the
Caption: Yvonne will flow into the view will
Caption: figure a redraw and the motorcycle -
Caption: completes right so this really this
Caption: pattern is really sort of pulling it'll
Caption: plus another version that's your great
Caption: way to write you eyes even outside of my
Caption: use this pack of JavaScript code is
Caption: commanding user and I built I think it's
Caption: really read all of these components that
Caption: completely stateless which makes them
Caption: really easy to test like the views only
Caption: dependencies it's just a function that
Caption: takes one argument but it's too crazy to
Caption: test that and same day it takes both the
Caption: argument depends on obviously
Caption: interesting piece in isolation
Caption: really obvious places illness and
Caption: functional language and this is a
Caption: functional path that go they kind of gel
Caption: together really nice in a way that Redux
Caption: I feel doesn't gel with and I can
Caption: hey go so this is an online American
Caption: preference for humbling those that's
Caption: right you know you got stuff in here
Caption: compiled so the stuff you like actually
Caption: draw something so HTML packaged and we
Caption: use this exposes an ex that basically
Caption: just means employed every information
Caption: you know
Caption: and then we have a main function of X
Caption: it's going to color it
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so the first function definition
Caption: application and then you provide as a
Caption: separated list of arguments in an equal
Caption: time and in the body of your options
Caption: there's no parentheses here
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so maybe not be found at how about we'll
Caption: do some conditional stuff right so I'm
Caption: gonna write a function thanks clover
Caption: Katzman it's not a message about whether
Caption: love you
Caption: someone said about 70 I feel like
Caption: because to me that's way before
Caption: reasonable suggestion 11 cats that's
Caption: greater than 2 and we just immediately
Caption: [Music]
Caption: else brunch good so let's actually run
Caption: best dish
Caption: you never know one of them otherwise Oh
Caption: it was quickly going to list since
Caption: accident you get into doing some more
Caption: HTML and interactivity up stuff listen
Caption: to nil basically the same as JavaScript
Caption: you just use square brackets
Caption: yeah pretty stressful with I feel like
Caption: this kind of you know this we can do to
Caption: string and print Paulus this printed and
Caption: here's actually printed the list itself
Caption: so that's why it goes this way
Caption: positive effects function that I guess
Caption: it's all fairly straightforward right so
Caption: well that they said let's do some actual
Caption: HTML and good programming here so we
Caption: have a div and we're going to give it a
Caption: list of attributes supposed to be like
Caption: HTML attributes in this case I'm just
Caption: gonna give it and then the second thing
Caption: you give it is a list of Charlie with us
Caption: it will do h1 say yeah I feel like this
Caption: index is probably one of the more
Caption: different things about writing HTML in
Caption: this way there are like transpilers and
Caption: that's writing the more reactive angle
Caption: bracket style but honestly you do very
Caption: quickly get used to this Thanks
Caption: to pets
Caption: hello a day to day throughout to cats
Caption: that the appropriate number of cats for
Caption: the girlfriends yes this is all class
Caption: ready board right but we still don't
Caption: have any activity and we also haven't
Caption: started using me home so to do that we
Caption: need this is really easy this is similar
Caption: the object syntax in in JavaScript so in
Caption: JavaScript you thought about that
Caption: and actually test this already without
Caption: the hola protection if I just spend you
Caption: and me so I put the final component we
Caption: need is our function as I said before
Caption: text message so now with these great
Caption: things what we need to do is wire them
Caption: together oh my good to go set up a
Caption: function to do this cross cooking in a
Caption: program you basically just give it the
Caption: view model update function and it will
Caption: make sure that everything
Caption: goats are awful and live together no
Caption: that's that's interactivity this cats
Caption: basically interchangeable even in solo
Caption: so the buttons render but obviously
Caption: they're not generating any actions right
Caption: so anytime normally end up close so that
Caption: lives in the package
Caption: all still works that we're not handle
Caption: this event so there's events and going
Caption: in tomorrow that function County M that
Caption: since I'm an ocean is into anything that
Caption: handle those so and eleven these various
Caption: and lead to the messages
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: just get rid of all this anyone's a
Caption: problem in this long for exactly right
Caption: yeah
Caption: so now since we're using strings is
Caption: possibly we pass a strain that as an
Caption: adult will sell and in that case it can
Caption: be a runtime a proxy because Ellen
Caption: doesn't know what to do in that case
Caption: so fortunately detect this as provide us
Caption: a really helpful our best engine so
Caption: we've got checks the case payment
Caption: handles or branches we save the strings
Caption: we need to accommodate for the site but
Caption: again this is a bit there's still some
Caption: problems to this right because if we
Caption: make it perfect you know it's stupid in
Caption: compiler as as far as Ellen's case and
Caption: yet we clearly have
Caption: so really what we want is we don't use
Caption: strings for these messages probably want
Caption: to use like an enum where union time so
Caption: that's just a type message and the
Caption: message can find the bait an adult will
Caption: sell pretty straightforward right you
Caption: can have as many of these MS o'clock and
Caption: then this is full so they only talk by a
Caption: correction type in this entire demo so
Caption: now what we need to do is we just each
Caption: of these two and obviously if we make
Caption: one of these composite you've tried to
Caption: be so but again keeping our both lanes
Caption: detected another era since the right now
Caption: passing through this enum type you can
Caption: only be and also sell so we don't
Caption: actually need this default because there
Caption: is no default case but handling very
Caption: possible
Caption: Google's so that's the demo of this
Caption: that's all for me that's a bit of a
Caption: taste of something to call the caterer
Caption: out there obviously I feel like pulling
Caption: into funny conference is different
Caption: people I hope you already see how smooth
Caption: it is that's really nice there is there
Caption: it really helped discover a lot of
Caption: things we know this is all thanks to you
Caption: know
Caption: you
Caption: really provides peace of mind and
Caption: confidence with your riding apartments a
Caption: really fun experience obviously you have
Caption: to write a lot less tests right the
Caption: composite catch me so many cases for you
Caption: you can have a much smaller really we
Caption: also saw how polite that requires it and
Caption: this isn't something I mentioned earlier
Caption: but like all the tools in the own
Caption: ecosystem have this kind of politeness
Caption: to them like the package manager doesn't
Caption: say install package yn is what they call
Caption: this a beautiful it doesn't sound like
Caption: life but I think it's nice system
Caption: architecture there it is the other
Caption: inspired you to give Elmo good like I
Caption: said before like you don't need to be
Caption: using this tape reduction to benefit
Caption: from it even if you just you know give
Caption: it a go and learn to write things in a
Caption: more functional and testable style you
Caption: just push for a better developer
Caption: experience from from your tools and your
Caption: languages I think that would be enough
Caption: like everything has to be world-changing
Caption: sometimes it really is just about the
Caption: little things those are links so
Caption: obviously don't let go go slash try this
Caption: I was using for the demo if you want
Caption: look at that well it includes that
Caption: doesn't example that you can go straight
Caption: in there right there's also a comb so
Caption: this is another in browser rebel so a
Caption: bit more features and the
Caption: one so lets you write javascript folks
Caption: to element and write some actual HTML
Caption: and stuff on that there's also that also
Caption: gave up requests this is a ton like a
Caption: wrinkled with tons of links to tools
Caption: articles tutorials stuff I really
Caption: recommend checking out any other tools
Caption: from the Creator Epogen that mean well
Caption: one of the heavy metal users development
Caption: they're really excellent speakers and
Caption: they've got along pretty good tools that
Caption: really hold it i lastly after the card
Caption: up for the demo on my github the 18 i've
Caption: included comments and this manager stuff
Caption: in there so you can just copy that
Caption: straight from one of the rifles and be
Caption: off to the races
Caption: let's vote for me thank you so much for
Caption: coming
Caption: if you have any questions place that as
Caption: affected just tap me on the shoulder off
Caption: was almost security
Caption: [Applause]